foreign
welcome to Hungry lamu a game by Kuru is
that blood on the trees
[Music]
hello lamu you had a good nap didn't you
oh dear looks like somebody's hungry
let's go find some food for that big
stomach of yours lamu
okay
why am I in a sewer
why is there a drip drop
oh is it so quiet
oh okay I was just in a cave
isn't it a beautiful day lamu let's find
some cherries to put in that stomach of
yours
go eat three cherries that's not a
cherry
I know cherries are red there aren't any
cherries Beyond this point
well that's not a cherry
that's not a cherry either
cherries grow on trees
[Music]
these are berries they're not cherries
they're berries
okay easy there llama
lamu I'm sorry too
[Music]
okay cool good this all seems fun
if I didn't know the name of this video
was three scary games I'd be worried
yum weren't those cherries delicious but
lamu is still hungry
cherries are not enough for lamu's
stomach oh what's that
what is that what well if it isn't a
cute little banana
it's not a banana lamu loves fruits I'm
sure this banana wouldn't mind helping
lamu
[Music]
let's go meet this banana lamu yeah
that's me eat eat the banana eat the
banana eat the banana talk
hello little banana
okay
oh dear looks like I was wrong the
banana is very selfish and doesn't want
to help lamu
[Music]
huh
we'll need to make that banana sleep
[Music]
so that lamu can have a delicious meal
need something
hard
[Music]
oh
no
[Music]
no
oh no no
[Music]
oh no
I could stop
right
oh no oh no
[Music]
what a hearty meal I'm sure the banana
didn't mind
despite its sour attitude it tasted very
sweet
however there's still some space in
lamu's big big stomach
oh what's that lamu
it's a bunch of Fruit Friends
we don't see a lot of them around here
probably because you eat them all lamu
their fruits should be enough to fill up
lamu's stomach let's go say hi to them
hi
thank you
looks like they want to play a game just
like the other fruit friends we've met
in the past how fun come on lamu let's
find our new friends so we can have some
of their delicious fruits oh no oh do I
need the rock do I not need I don't
think I need the rock hello need
something stinging like fire
bees
perfect
all right
problem number one solved throbies
[Music]
I found Apple
ouch the bee stung me everywhere looks
like I've got to be careful next time
have my Apple you be serve it
[Music]
it's fine
it's all good
it's all fine I need something hot well
I mean
fire technically speaking
ah oh
swing ax hey who's up there who's up
there hey whoa that was a high fall did
you know oranges give you tons of energy
have mine maybe next time you'll be able
to climb a tree too
oh hi what hello hello hello
oh that's just in the woods Hi friend
light bush
oh God that's hot hot hot hot hot oh
geez I couldn't you try something less
burning well I hope you like burned pear
because it's all yours
Yum Yum Yum weren't your fruit friends
just Delicious lemon
what a great day playing with friends
eating delicious fruits and having such
fun today was a marvelous day wasn't it
lamu
oh what's that lamu
you're still hungry
oh what
what the hell
sounded like Tasha
I told them not to make so much Ruckus
let's see what they're up to
oh my God no don't do this to me no no
no
no no no no no no no
so that's what I saw down at the bottom
of the map was this guy peeing me oh no
oh no
I found the campsite where did they all
go
where's mochi
oh where are you girl she couldn't have
run off too far
oh no
oh no
mochi
Mochi girl
emoji
oh no
oh no
oh my God no Emoji what the [ __ ] who did
this poor girl whichever of you [ __ ]
did this this is [ __ ] up Tasha Ken
Leon where the hell are you guys why
wouldn't you think that was like an
animal
oh no
oh
oh man I don't like anything that I have
I didn't do it but man this is oh
ah
oh B oh bees oh no no no
no oh no I'm gonna be sick why are there
so many
damn bees who did this to you Ken
no
no
oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God
oh no
oh what did I just see
oh my God I just saw something why why
did I just see something oh oh no no oh
God Tasha she must have Twisted her leg
in the tree
what the hell did this to her oh my God
I'm blind
okay it was like a burned Bush I'm
looking oh
looking for a burned bush
oh there it is okay I see it okay well I
don't know what's in store for me once I
find this burned Bush oh no
great
holy [ __ ] I don't even recognize him
he's burnt to a crisp what the hell is
going on I have to get out of here
I need to get my car
where is
my Carby what is that in front of me no
no car car
hmm
oh hi llama I love you
car please I have car this is car I'm at
car
safe
I can relax now
oh okay
ending one of two
what do you mean what was supposed to be
a peaceful camping trip for four friends
turned into a devastating bloodbath
Tasha Ken Leone and blank were camping
in the lamu forest park on the night of
the February 19th the young adults just
graduated and were looking to have a
getaway on the wild to unwind and relax
that was when tragedy occurred Tasha Ken
and Leon were brutally murdered and
decapitated in the middle of the night
leaving blank to be the Lone Survivor of
the devastating incident the lamu forest
park has been Infamous due to its
collection of known murders to those who
entered the park every murder involved
within the park has been through
decapitation by unknown means though
I just noticed the law moves in the back
there though forensics have concluded
that bite marks present on the deceased
bodies resemble that of human teeth The
Mystery of the lamu killer has been
solved due to recent developments though
authorities have decided to withhold the
information of details about said killer
they assure the public that it will no
longer cause any harm to any citizens
blank has refused to participate in any
interviews understandably due to their
traumatizing experience our deepest
condolences to the family of Tasha Ken
and Leon the public May rest easy
knowing the lamu killer has been
apprehended
oh roadkill is in I ran it over
great I really like that where it goes
from this happy top down to Slender the
force test 3D very fun very cool I do
like that very cool
moving on
welcome to the pizza freak now I think
this might be a Chuck E cheese inspired
horror game or it might just be about
delivering pizza of which there have
been numerous horror games
but this one is probably a little bit
more silly if I had to imagine I don't
really have any basis for that judgment
but I'm making the Judgment all the same
are you judging me for making the
judgment
okay
something's a little off here
where's the ground
huh
love the aesthetic of the way the lights
are going it's beautiful except for the
whole fact that the ground's missing
maybe it's less silly than I thought
maybe it's a little bit more serious
hmm
current objective thoughts semi-current
objective
oh
ah current objective deliver pizza
thoughts I need some sleep
well first I gotta make my money so I
need to deliver my pizza I'm assuming
that I go here I backed into the
cul-de-sac or I pulled a sweet
180 hello
where do I deliver
the one you're pointed to
maybe hello pizza
hello
I I'm uh you you you
oh you oh
okay well they somehow managed to make
that the creepiest thing in the world
okay I did it
do I do anything else do I deliver pizza
to all the lid houses over here
oh my God hello
okay
I think this is the part where I just
want to work out
oh I don't know why only when I start
running I just go and then I stop I
guess everyone on the street needs some
pizza
hello hi thank you
you're welcome
okay
hello
no not you not you hello never mind
hello never mind I'm not exactly sure
who needs pizza and who don't
okay never mind
might be the ones
where the lights are on inside
why
okay that's totally fine
probably high
hello
uh
thanks
oh [ __ ] they're coming what you better
watch out with those pizzas what do you
find you what do you mean what does that
even mean what does that even mean
I have to go to the car why
why do I have to go to the car why do I
have to go to the car I don't understand
okay what wants Pizza
and is cause for alarm throughout the
entirety of the city
so that they need to blast the emergency
alarms I'm at my car I am literally at
well that was incredibly unfair and how
dare you I need to get out of here I
have no thoughts head empty Must Escape
is that a vending machine oh good well I
was thirsty I need some j-stream juice
some stream juice I'm hopped up on the
juice can I get some juice I need some
juice I ain't streaming but I might be
later give me the juice no juice okay
fine then
I'll just continue on This Way Lady da
La delita no juice to keep me going
God I need some gamer beans hey juice
hey can I get some juice
some gamer juice for me thank you please
please please
please I need it I've never needed
anything so oh
God there's got to be some juice around
here somewhere
oh hello hi what is this oh door whoa
oh it is opening
ah
juice I think something might have gone
wrong
with my pizza delivery and also with my
experience in this void of death
ah juice no that's weird
is anybody gonna explain to me what's um
the happy haps oh
okay oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
hey wow okay
I don't know if I believe that also
there's an earthquake
looks you can make this really intense
because tamasha's shaking I can't even
see anymore Lexi an attempt to stabilize
the footage here so that it makes more
sense for the people watching I'm sure
that'll work just fine definitely
let me in oh wait
[Music]
um
I don't know about that one
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
all right what do they have it the pizza
freak that that made a lot of sense and
I understand why the the icon was Chuck
E cheese all right good game not bad not
bad not bad
moving on you're welcome to feed your
cat I think this is the cat game that
everyone's been talking about you know
where you've got the cat
that can anyway controls walking jump
interact Escape okay
um I've been told that this game has a
lot of endings
lovely art really uh impressive is that
a bottle of blood is that a bottle of
blood
herbs and spices
okay
hmm I think I remember a game called
like feed your dog or something like
that
it's locked okay
hmm
something wrong with your stove
very strong boys and probably shouldn't
be mixed with cat food prop probably
very strong poison probably shouldn't be
mixed with cat food oh no
I hope I didn't need that
it's been a lot never since the sail
incident he he
was since the what incident since the
what
okay
I think I threw away the food
remind
I found the cat food
uh apparently
I'm disconcerted what is oh
oh
hmm okay I can't get up all right so I
got the cat food
I'm pretty sure the name of the game was
feed the cat so I think I
feed the cat
it's displaying a picture of a strange
guy of a strange God okay sure
Kitty
[Music]
hi Kitty
oh hi
what
oh my God hi Kitty how are you doing
this is my cat I should probably feed it
okay I'm gonna do that
[Music]
good job you fed the cat you get to live
another day but there is more to it okay
all right I'm intrigued what happens if
I put herbs and spices
with the cat food I don't know if cats
like herbs and spices
oh
should I put this in the thing if I put
this in the bowl first does that do
anything
it does nothing what is that
this rock has been here since forever
since forever you say
I see why oh
do I live at courage's house Courage the
Cowardly Dog
in the middle of nowhere
oh epic cat food recipe poison cat foods
3D lettuce spices mix all in Bowl huh
don't drink sus juice
okay
got nothing to say about this
okay
a bowl
oh I wonder if I can pick up the
sledgehammer
oh I can this is either for the lock or
The Rock
I'm not sure which
[Music]
law
it's got to be the rock don't mind me
kitty
that is convenient I feel like I could
have just smashed the lock but this is
much more better ER
oh
wow that is 3D lettuce that is um
yeah that's pretty good that's pretty
good
okay so that and then that and that's
locked but if I put if I put the cat
food with the cat poison then it's gonna
make really epic cat food
okay and then I just need the such juice
hold on Kitty
I don't think that there's a timer
I don't think that there's some kind of
a
press e to drink
uh I'll wait till next time I'll drink
it um after I do this
oh
oh
I guess this is really epic cat food
okay hi Kitty hi how you doing here you
go wow
oh your cat never needs to be fed again
as the food you gave her was so good you
now live a Carefree life well that's
weird I'm gonna go drink a bottle of
wine or blood or whatever it is okay bye
Kitty don't don't look around this
corner you know I guess I'm personal
business to take care of around this
corner
an old friend of mine
oh
that's very weird okay
e
[Music]
H listen just blow it up
okay so that's four of six or three of
six that I've gotten I've gotten half
the endings I'm sure one of them is um
poisoning the cat not that I really
would do that in life but I'm a
completionist and therefore I need to
explore all the Avenues
probably
okay it's poisoned right I'm gonna is
this cat not actually evil and uh even
though it looks very extremely evil
two-dimensional
[Music]
no
no I managed to kill poison kill my cat
you're an awful human being a GP I
didn't well okay I thought you know it's
a game it really sets itself up like a
war game I thought there was some like
cthulhu-esque horror that was embedded
in the the cat you know oh yeah well
yeah that's uncomfortable all right the
only other thing that comes to mind in
my quest to be a super good and awesome
guy
is to take the sledgehammer
yeah yeah I'm gonna try to open the door
okay guys
can you tell me what I should do next
oh no
we're good we're good I could probably
feed it we're good we're good we're good
we're good okay so the question now is
what do I do now that I try I didn't try
that I've never tried that I refuse is
this camera have a texture of a road
maybe a road
take that what if I throw everything
away
what if I throw it away
oh yeah
[Music]
okay well that did absolutely nothing
um now I have no food and nothing with
which to feed the cat so therefore
there's nothing really I can do
I know you're evil kitty I know somehow
you're evil you must be evil this is a
horror game there's got to be some evil
components to this
okay I spoiled myself on something but I
didn't spoil you guys on what that
something was so I'm going to make it as
scary as possible for you to experience
the thing that I spoiled for myself in
fact I'm going to remove myself from the
equation exactly now
foreign
I don't know what I was expecting goofy
ending okay what all right so I've
gotten five of the six endings I've fed
the cat I have definitely not murdered
the cat I fed the cat really good food
I've drank sus juice and then I faded
fed it lettuce there's got to be
something else in here to feed this cat
that which I have not fed yet
whoa wait a minute
wait a minute very interesting okay all
right we have a keypad that was
definitely not there before therefore
there is something else here to explore
this is my cat
I see you there
look behind the sink don't you worry
I'll look behind the sink all right
oh
wow I don't know what that means Okay so
it's a puzzle we got binary so we're
looking at oh 100
all right and that's
binary to text
ah okay so that that binary just says
base 64 which means I need to go into a
base64 translator
nine two one three eight am I still
capturing properly well I did
um assume I pressed the right button
nine two one three eight
I should use it with my hammer
no need to tell me twice I should use it
with my hammer I've also often thought
that the hammer is the solution to all
life's problems hello get ready for
hammer
oh I know what I must do now but I know
not if I have the strength to do it
hi Kitty
this is my okay okay that's not what it
was that's not what it was I apologize
look you're judging me but it's not true
it's that's not what I was thinking I
was going just to pet the cat real quick
because that's all I was gonna do and
then
nope okay
um interesting can I pull down the
boards
[Music]
with this now for some reason
oh
all right that's good
hello
oh
what
oh
hi
hello
oh you're oh
an old friend of mine wow okay
Oh weird
oh my goodness
um hey oh hey I've been locked in this
room for 11 years wait you are the one
who locked me in here are you
well that doesn't matter now what
matters is killing your cat who is
secretly
that boys and you gave them earlier
didn't actually work it was just my game
been too old for this but you still have
time here have this Fork use it to kill
the cat and free the universe once and
for all
goodbye player
oh
thank you I am a player and old friend
of mine okay all right I guess I go kill
the cat now look it uh not my idea when
your giant seal tells you to kill your
cat I'm guessing that's really a
no-brainer
oh no
[Music]
oh hey let's talk about this hey uh
let's not be too hasty let's not be too
wasted hey who's a good kitty who's a
good kitty
was a good kitty it was a good kitty hey
how's the weather was a good kitty sure
I guess this is it I always knew that
Sheila would try to kill me one day and
ruined my whole plan that room should
never have been unlocked
guess I have to go now are you happy
with what you did I hope not
just know that this is not the end
goodbye I'll be seeing you
okay goodbye oh oh
what what
huh what's it good or bad I don't know I
didn't expect so much lore in a silly
beating your cat horror game I guess it
wasn't horror was it horror was this
even horror this is horror or was it
like a surreal experience that allowed
you to get in contact with your true
self
I don't know anyway pretty good
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]